Es ist ein riesiger riss und er ist der vorbote eines
unglaublichen geologischen ereignisses der kilometer langes ist 15 meter tief 20 meter breit und hat bereits häuser
Und straßen zerstört er ist der erste vorbote der abspaltung des ostafrikanischen
Kontinents der entsteht dort gerade enden wird der riss in einem neuen mehr
Dass sich zwischen rest afrika und aus afrika schien wird was jetzt passiert und was das wäre dann kenia bedeutet jetzt den klicks um science-fiction
herzlich willkommen
Vielen dank erstmal für den themenvorschlag auf whatsapp mehrere leute aus der community hatten das thema entdeckt und mir gemeldet
Wir auch dort teil meiner redaktion werden könnt erfahrt, am ende
Des videos dieser riss ist erst der anfang er war die folge von starken regenfällen und brachte zum ersten mal das
auseinanderbrechen das abbrechen einer neuen
kontinentalplatte an die erdoberfläche plötzlich ging nichts mehr auf der
maybachstraße in kenia die vielbefahrene straße wurde durch den riss unterbrochen und musste erst wieder
aufwendig repariert werden häuser wurden zerstört und was jetzt immer klarer wird das ist erst der anfang dieser riss wird sich durch ganz kenia
Ziehen und das land langsam teilen am anfang wird es nur eine schlucht sein die sich aber immer weiter auf teilt bis meerwasser
einströmen wird und das land irgendwann auf zwei kontinenten liegen wird grund ist der
ostafrikanischen graben verläuft vom horn von afrika bis nach mosambik
Im süden tausende kilometer lang und entlang driften die westliche nubische platte und die östliche
Somalische platte aus anderen da jedes jahr um 200 zentimeter alle 40 jahre sind es einen meter in 400 jahren also zehn meter und in
4000 jahren 100 meter es wird also noch etwas dauern bis sich die platten trennen aber es wird immer besser
zu sehen sein in der geologie wird damit gerechnet dass es 20 bis 60 millionen jahre dauert bis hier wirklich ein neuer kontinent
Entstanden ist allerdings ist der riss dem mann jetzt in kenia sieht nicht direkt. Genau die stelle an der die kontinentalplatten
auseinanderbrechen vielmehr entstehen durch das
auseinanderdriften hohlräume und ihm die werden bei regen sand und erde von der oberfläche gespült oben rutscht die erde
Danach und es tun sich immer mehr risse auf und wahrscheinlich wird das entlang des ostafrikanischen
grabens immer mehr passen werden zerstört häuser und wahrscheinlich werden durch diese tektonischen bewegungen auch neue vulkane entstehen
Geologisch wird es also sehr spannend in afrika in zeiträumen von vielen millionen jahren
Wenn er als erstes neues zu neuen kontinenten und geologie und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann endet hier
meine telefonnummer whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
täglich
Garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt über mich in der redaktion freundlich so mitmachen und mir eben themen vorschlagen oder an abstimmungen teilnehmen und mitbestimmen was
hier bei pixum passiert der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo mit der
Glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch. Draufklicken achter kontinent entdeckt expedition unterwegs ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran